par 16 français quelles que soient ses
halosonic vous est dirigée à mort deux
mois de toute façon we want you back
voilà une punchline comme jean lassalle
les a multipliées pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 mais en fait jean
nasa n'a pas attendu la course à
l'elysée pour nous étonner
jean lassalle verger maire de lourdios
ichère dans la vallée d'aoste dans le
béarn dans les pyrénées atlantiques
alors sans grande surprise les coupés
avec françois bayrou de m
en 2002 le berger des pyrénées arrivent
à paris dans son costume de député
plutôt discret pendant presqu'un an
jusqu'à ce que s'il vous plaît vous
pouvez vous asseoir
jean lassalle se met à chanter l'hymne
occitan
c'est sa manière à lui d'exprimer son
désaccord au ministre de l'intérieur sur
un dossier local
vous n'avez pas entendu fredonner pas de
problème il remet ça pour les caméras
[Musique]
à agneaux détonne un peu dans les rangs
de l'assemblée
et ça ne s'arrête pas là trois ans plus
tard pour sauver une entreprise
implantée dans le béarn qui souhaitent
déménager en 2006 jean lassalle entament
une grève de la faim
quand quelqu'un se jette alors pour un
saut vers notre île n'est pas désespérée
il a peur peut-être formule de cette
note d'espoir ce qu'ils pensent trente
neuf jours deux jeunes gens nacelle a
fini à l'hôpital mais qu'importe il a
gagné son pari et sauvé une centaine
d'emplois en bon berger jean lassalle
est un député qui marchent quitte à
sécher les sessions de l'assemblée en
pendant que ses collègues sont en
commission lui il est en road trip pour
écouter et recueillir les idées des
français et des françaises
je vais dire bonjour madame
[Musique]
définitivement c'est presqu'une
obsession pour le député berger encore
pendant la campagne présidentielle a de
quoi fédérer outre mesure il obtient
1,21 % des voix au premier tour de la
présidentielle 2017
mais jean lassalle res une haute figure
de la politique en pyrénées atlantiques
député depuis 2002 réélu trois fois est
resté maire de sa commune pendant 40 ans
[Musique]